UNIONS DON’T WANT TO LET THEIR
TEACHERS TEACH BUT LET’S TALK
ABOUT SOMETHING NOT AS UPBEAT AS
THAT.
IT IS SOMETHING EVEN MORE
DISCONCERTING AND THAT IS WHAT’S
HAPPENING AT THE BORDER.
STEVE: IT IS A MESS.
WE TOLD YOU THAT IN THE
ADMINISTRATION WON’T CALL IT A
CRISIS.
KAMALA HARRIS HAS BEEN PUT IN
CHARGE OF TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
THE ROOT CAUSES AND WHY ALL
THESE PEOPLE FROM CENTRAL
AMERICA COME HERE.
WE KNOW WHY.
IT’S EASY TO GET ACROSS THE
BORDER.
NONETHELESS, THERE SHE WAS DOING
A ZOOM CALL AT THE WASHINGTON
CONFERENCE ON THE AMERICAS AND
LISTEN TO SOME OF THE WORLD
LEADERS SHE IS TALKING TO ABOUT
THE ROOT CAUSES AND WHAT THEY
CAN DO TO HELP US.
>> THIS IS A PRIORITY FOR OUR
NATION AND A ROLE THAT I TAKE
VERY SERIOUSLY.
THE CITIZENS OF EL SALVADOR,
GUATEMALA, HONDURAS ARE LEAVING
THEIR HOMES AT A ALARMING RATES.
THEY ARE SUFFERING AND IN PAIN
AND MANY ARE EXPERIENCING
UNIMAGINABLE ANGUISH AND SO WE
ARE FOCUSED ON ADDRESSING BOTH
THE ACUTE FACTORS AND THE ROOT
CAUSES OF MIGRATION.
I BELIEVE THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION.
WE MUST FOCUS ON BOTH.
I’VE ALSO SPOKEN WITH WORLD
LEADERS FROM CANADA, FINLAND,
IRELAND, JAPAN ABOUT PARTNERING
WITH US TO HELP THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE.
BRIAN: PLEASE, IRELAND STOPPED
SITTING BACK GREAT FAMILY, HELP.
IT IS OBVIOUSLY SOMETHING THAT
IS ON FINLAND’S MIND WORRIED
ABOUT CENTRAL AMERICA AND WHY
WOULD THEY BE?
BY THE WAY, FINLAND WAS VOTED
THE HAPPIEST COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD.
AINSLEY: SO THE PLAN IS FOR
BILLION-DOLLAR PLAN AND SHE
ANNOUNCED THE 310 MILLION-DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN THAT REGION AND
SAYS SHE WANTS TO GO TO HONDURAS
AND DELIVER FOOD, SHELTER, WATER
TO THE PEOPLE, GUATEMALA SHE
WANTS TO WORK WITH FARMERS TO
PLANT DROUGHT RESISTANT CROPS
AND HELP WOMEN FARMERS INCREASE
THEIR CROPS.
BRIAN: WHAT ABOUT OUR CROPS?
STEVE: THIS IS A CRISIS AS WE
ALL KNOW IN A FAIRLY ONE OF THE
PLANS IS TO SEND OR SPEND
$4 BILLION SO HOW MUCH MONEY ARE
WE GOING TO SEND DOWN TO THOSE
COUNTRIES BECAUSE WE KNOW HOW IT
WORKS?
THE MORE MONEY WE SEND DOWN
THERE, YOU KNOW,  WE WILL SEND
YOU $4 BILLION, STOP THE PEOPLE
FROM COMING AND IF THEY STOP THE
PEOPLE FROM COMING THEN WE WOULD
STOP SENDING THEM THE MONEY.
DO YOU REALLY THINK THAT WILL
ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSE AND STOP
PEOPLE FROM COMING?
BRIAN: NOT A CHANCE.
AINSLEY: JEN PSAKI SAID THE
PROBLEM GOES BACK TO TRUMPS
POLICIES THAT ARE GIVING US SO